it's time for et's Kardashian ketchup
Rob can be really irrational and he just
has to learn to really take
responsibility for himself and not blame
it on China in the latest Keeping Up
with the Kardashians Kim tries to calm
down
Rob after his explosive split with blac
Chyna where she left with baby dream
[Music]
it's so clear what this relationship is
and that they're just not meant to be
with each other then there's Kim K
looking ultra chic steppin out in a
black figure fitting dress for a
shopping trip with her pals in LA I want
to wear things that make me feel good
about myself I think it's a really
positive step in a great direction and
Kris at Caitlyn Jenner work on putting
the past behind them over a glass of
wine hippies glasses for 25 years and
now you want a gun actually the only
problem I have with with the gun being
it's registered and my old name I've got
to get that changed I've got everything
changed but in some states I think if
you go through gender confirmation
surgery it's the only way you can Wow
yeah would you have done that if you
already we have you know what what don't
even go down this road cuz I'm not
talking about it
you